Same document fragment as before, except we've
now added a CSS style sheet at the
top that renders all paragraph text in
black. Now, consider what happens when we try
to execute our inline JavaScript. We region to the document and find all the
paragraph tags. Grab the first one and set up it's CSS on color style to red.
>> The style sheet says that all paragraphs
should be rendered with black text. What if this
CSS style sheet arrives after the script is already executed and sets the color
to red? Would the browser be smart enough to figure out which color to use?
>> Yes, it would. Here's a quick diagram that illustrates what actually happens.
The browser requests the HTML, and as soon as it gets the response,
it starts building the DOM. It then discovers the CSS and sends the
request. Then, the parser continues and finds the script tag, at which point
it has to block. It doesn't know what the script is going to
do because the script may want to try accessing the CSS properties. So, it
blocks script execution until the css arrives and we build the css object
model. Only then can we run the JavaScript and then finish building the DOM.
>> Wow, so CSS blocks rendering and it blocks JavaScript execution.
>> Exactly,
which is, once again why optimizing your css is so
important. On that note, I have a quick quiz for you.